and by the way it's snow crap but it's
still crab baby every time I'm at a
buffet and I see that line for the crab
legs I'm like thank God I don't like
Chris
[Music]
how do you guys feel about Flonase
I was like what I want fog
hope this is off the Record all right
we'll talk about that after is that what
we're talking about no no it's Cinco de
Mayo yeah some slow days on your penis
it's a slow day I thought you said fall
day you put floaties on your penis or
your penis supposed to have fun today
and then we switched them because Cinco
de Mayo so we're gonna try it no anyways
what's a floating how do y'all feel
about
when a plane
lands and then there's those people
those passengers just like get up get up
right away and then try to go straight
anyway
that's you why you do that I don't get
to the front but I like standing up
right away because I've been sitting
down the whole time uh that's why you
stand during the how far how far you are
you standing up and like is it just
stand up or are you like standing up
going to the aisle grab your bags and
stuff while the seatbelt sign is still
on like what what's the stand up
oh I just stand up and then I kind of
like uh de-separate my ball sack from my
leg I'm gonna sit there for a long time
it's all stuck together standard
protocol but do you do it with the seat
belt on or do that I go like that but do
you wait but do you wait till it goes
and then they turn off the seat and then
you take it oh yeah I follow the I
follow the signs yeah there's a lot of
impatient [__] that'll like
just people yeah oh dude the people who
just act like there's not another human
being that exists and they go all the
way to the front of the plane oh follow
those guys don't do that I've seen
people just grab [__] they just run to
the front you know that's that's dumb I
just stand up and then if someone run
past me I just let them pass me I just
want to de-separate my testicles from my
legs it does work though if you're like
oh it's okay I'm a big YouTuber yeah
that's that's the only time for
everyone's like oh my bad I didn't know
that okay what if they did that were
they seated rather than groups be
through C whatever they're just like all
right if anyone with 10 000 or more subs
yeah
that's a long time I can tell you there
they will Flex being a YouTuber for no
they'll just get up and go to the front
of the [__] plane because they're a
big deal and then if people ask them
[__] they're just like what [__] I
don't care
that would Ray William Johnson do that
that is the thing no names if they not
till the book comes out I think those
moments if they communicate clearly
they're like hey sorry I have a
connecting flight that we just got like
delayed from so like do you mind sure
easy totally totally so much empathy
well your basic human situations that's
supposed to be the flight attendant's
job because they know that the flight
was delayed there's connectors and they
go please uh people have that have
connectors please let them go first yeah
yeah they do do that sometimes yeah but
if they don't then they're [__]
because you're the one that has to say
hey I have a I have a connector and I
gotta say a lot of the times there's
some old Chinese people
oh dude mainlanders yeah for sure what
they just they just stand up and Rush
yeah like it's a [__] it's the most
important thing to get off the plane
very very quickly to get into the
Customs lives as quickly as possible in
order to avoid you know what I mean
there's there's definitely some Chinese
people that have a total disregard for
how Society feels about what they're
doing yeah is it because in China I kind
of respect they have to do that or else
they're not going to get a chance yeah I
think so it's like when you go to a
buffet in China and everyone's just arms
are like all over you yeah we're just
grabbing the crab legs it is because you
are also you'll never get a crab legs
[__] the king crab the new crab out oh
God it looks crazy it's crazy and and by
the way it's snow crap it's the [__] one
it's about Dungeness but it's still crab
every time I'm at a buffet and I see
that line for the crab legs I'm like
thank God I don't like crabs yeah like
it feels good dude As Americans we can't
really complain though because we got
like Walmart Fiasco's on oh yeah we do
the same thing no it's different
different strokes Chinese people made me
wish out a flamethrower
because [__] like I don't like
we'll be at the supermarket only the
Chinese guys can come no we're at the
supermarket Riley [__] chills like
looking around like [__] okay ground
beef and like just normal like human
distance it's like
and they're like still yeah yeah right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no the
sense of privacy is also weird so like
let's say if you like um like let's say
you're at a restaurant
yeah
you know they're like oh they're having
the pork chop I'll order that Chinese
people just straight up come to your
table
[Laughter]
we're in a booth we asked for the boot
we're in a booth for a reason
you like that remember I was telling you
when I was in China we went to a
amusement park and then every time we
were in line there would be other like
Chinese people that would just kind of
into it and they would inch past you in
the line and then I asked our guide I
was like what the [__] is this and he
goes no you have it's your job to like
stop them yeah you have to give them
anything they'll take it's weird like
yeah
you're like just on your phone or
whatever you can feel eyeballs you're
like
um excuse me they're all breathing on
you and this is the Chinese American
it's just from over there the rules are
[__] it's like a population density
effect too like when there's so many
people that's true it's like you got to
get what you can get because when I
first went to Japan and in Tokyo when it
was so crowded we kept bumping into each
other and I was like these [__]
are so rude and then I was like well if
you have to say excuse me every 15 10
seconds it's inefficient that's true
because you're that's true like you know
Shibuya Crossing you know during traffic
it's traffic jams of humans so you're
just bumping into each other like left
and right and you just don't have time
to say it's getting concussed on the way
that's true I was I was uh talking with
Jackson and he was he was making a
comment too he's like hey how come in
America whenever like a dude sees
another dude you like gotta be like
wait what's up you know what I mean
there's always some sort of like
acknowledgment if you make eye contact
with somebody you make eye contact
though I do that I think it's just to
establish or cool right like that right
exactly okay because like in Asia if you
just stare at the [__] you just
stare at a [__]
you know what I'm talking about right
that's true if I just choose
them look at you I'll give what I'm
judging or not doesn't matter it is I'm
just gonna look at you sometimes they
look at you with their mouth open too
like and their shirt tied up with their
belly yeah but in America if you do that
somebody might be like why are you
dogging me fool like we got a problem I
do that on Hikes when I'm walking by
somebody and I go
hello oh yeah for sure or at least
you're letting people know your thoughts
yeah you know so oh I'm cool you know
and that's cool but they never just like
[Laughter]
gets my heart racing a little bit dude
my neighbors all waving me and [__] like
I'm in my neighborhood just walking
around and my neighbors wave and I'm I
had it took me like six months to get
used to it yeah because I just want to
be a lay boy like like don't wave don't
look don't acknowledge like cookies yeah
that's true yeah
big city yeah but then you know I come
in from California they're probably like
great another California in here but
then it took me some time and then I
started waving a little [__] yeah it is
weird too especially when you've lived
in apartments and you follow you like
find the same people in there you really
don't look at each other no really even
in apartments huh no I know I I always
thought it was weird to do that
like big city Behavior though you don't
have that small town hi to everybody
yeah so when you go into a small town
and people say hi to you you're like oh
[__] I'm being rude yeah I'm just not
used to but I was talking that through
Brute Force because I moved to LA from
San Diego and I was always nice to
people right but then like I come to La
I live in an apartment building I'm like
hi what's up and then they're just like
because you share laundry rooms too you
don't talk to anyone in there when
you're doing your [__] yeah it's weird
but I think it's also because in the
city there's so much crazy that people
just or like maybe even girls if it's a
girl to even worse because it's like you
don't want to invite someone to talk to
you yeah yeah yeah and there's that
rotating door of like la like living as
well like yeah you don't have a
community ever yeah like oh my
grandparents have been living here in
this house and my parents got this house
and now I'm living at the top it's like
I signed a six-month lease you know what
I mean so you're not trying to build
relationships with like people that are
in and out but also too like the worst
thing in the world probably top five
things ever is when you talk to someone
and you realize they're a little crazy
and then now you're roped in a
conversation
you're like oh [__] I shouldn't have
never said yeah like oh God that's the
worst I feel like that's true for a lot
of cities just worldwide yeah right like
there's less of that small talk whatever
but then if you go into a small town
like people just talk to you because
they don't have to deal with as many
crazies as we do but sometimes
especially before cell phones got as fun
as they did I'd be on the subway in LA
and I'd get next to like a guy and then
the guy's like tell me about how he
killed JFK and I'm like yes dang is that
right it was so boring and I did my
phone didn't work down there and I'm
like all right I'm locked in bro how'd
you kill him yeah like what happened
that day and all that oh my God
you meet a lot of people like it is true
when you do talk to people the rate of
that they're weird is pretty high in the
city
dude in the city you just don't want to
you just wanna like not open any doors
or or is the rate of weird being high
because you rarely talk to random people
you know what I mean where it's like you
get accustomed to your circle or your
network of people and then when you go
talk to one random stranger they're
gonna be a little bit more outside of
that Circle so it seems weird but if you
just talk to weird people all the time
then nothing's weird anymore you know
yeah that's true but you don't want to
talk to weird people all the time that's
true I had a guy coming to the gym the
other day and I was training a client
and this guy comes in and he's inquiring
about Jiu Jitsu he goes hey off the Jump
I was like this is weird and I was like
what's up man how are you and he goes do
you guys
um do martial arts here and I go yeah I
was like you're interested in taking
class he's like do you guys break bones
and rip like me's and I go
well that's part of the martial art but
we don't like we try not to do that
right and he goes he goes good because
it's really important I learn this
martial art because I have a bunch of
stalkers and people trying to kill me so
I need to learn how to paranoid skits
and then already it's like how do I
navigate this conversation how do I
still extract money from this person
well as I'm talking to him I realize
like okay this dude is probably like not
let's give him a black belt send them
off yeah and then my dumb ass trying to
do this you should be like we don't get
to the knee breaking stuff until your
sixth year yeah so you could prepay the
entire program that would ruin the whole
class for everyone but this guy comes in
and you I already know he looks at the
price sheet and he's like oh this is a
little too expensive and I was like oh
it's okay blah blah and then he's like
is there other gyms in the area and I
was like yeah there's so many gyms in
the area is she good like you should go
shop around a little bit
[Music]
thank you